So now that captain rogers and iron man are both
gone who do you think's gonna lead the avengers
I could lead them
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new eternals video all about thanos because he
is an eternals character he does descend from
the eternal so i'll explain their connection
marvel just released a brand new synopsis for the
eternals movie that more directly connects them to
thanos josh brolin was also talking about coming
back and doing new thanos in mcu movies and jim
starlin the creator thanos said that marvel was
also discussing doing more with thanos in the mcu
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we have new loki episodes starting next
week i'll be doing videos for all those and we're
doing a disney plus giveaway for membership
so all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want them
to do with thanos in the future marvel movies
but if you missed it recently right after they
released the brand new eternals trailer marvel
also released some new merch that featured this
new synopsis for the movie that changes the
eternal's character's relationship with thanos
just a little bit they've already changed the
eternal's backstory for the movie so i will
explain some of those changes and why they
made them because some of them are bigger than
others but this brand new synopsis for the movie
just reads living on saturn's moon titan the
eternals protect earth from the deviants and
all other forms of cosmic evil it's a very brief
and very broad synopsis but it claims that these
eternals lived on the same moon titan that
was thanos's home before it was destroyed as
he explained during avengers infinity war this
was that scene let me guess your home it was
and it was beautiful remember the fall of titan
was thanos's whole motivation he had been banished
when he was much younger for his ideas and it
was while he was living in exile in another part
of the universe the titan eventually succumbed to
the effects of overpopulation and destabilization
thus he then set on his quest to assemble
the infinity gauntlet but originally in the
comics the eternals that came from titan were just
referred to as titans but genetically they were no
different from the original eternals characters
the first big change to the eternal's backstory
in the eternals movie is actually about the
deviants because we're talking about thanos
here and he carries the deviance gene even though
he's technically an eternal so this is why he
looks like purple space grimace with the nutsack
chin originally the deviants were this genetic
offshoot of the original eternals created by the
celestials jack kirby just envisioned them as this
monstrous genetically deformed villainous race
they were always trying to subjugate humanity and
kill the eternals off sometimes you would
have rogue eternals like druid who would try
to exploit the deviants in their own plots to gain
control over the eternals and humans alike when we
get some more footage of the eternals movie i'll
do separate videos about the different eternals
characters because druid for example is kind of
the loki of the family it's kind of the black
sheep he doesn't agree with what the eternals are
doing on earth he thinks that they should rule
over humans but he is not the main villain of the
movie he's just one of the antagonists during the
story but the second big change that they're
making in the eternals movie is saying that
these eternals were created and then they came to
planet earth and they're going with the ancient
aliens explainer is the way kevin feige explained
it the way that ajax saw mahayak's character talks
in her voice over in the trailer they've watched
over and guided humans so i think it's a bit of
a balance between those two concepts the ancient
aliens concepts like they themselves didn't build
all these complex structures but they influenced
humanity and helped teach them to do this
themselves but originally in the comics the
eternals were created by the celestials after
the first celestial host came to planet earth
to experiment with early homo sapiens and the
really cool reason why they originally came to
earth in the first place is because they saw odin
and agamoto the same agamotto who created the time
stone the eye of agamotto that doctor strange uses
they saw them in their ancient team of prehistoric
avengers kill one of the other celestials as the
celestial lay dying just bleeding out its
celestial blood rich with cosmic energy into
the planet it called out to the other celestials
telling them to come and cleanse the planet wipe
them all out so any time a new group of celestials
comes to earth they call it a new celestial host
so there's like a first celestial host that
creates the eternals then there's a second
celestial host that comes back creates another
big calamity then a third then a fourth but
originally these eternals characters in the movie
these main characters are actually the children
and grandchildren of the original ones that were
created by the celestials on earth and then they
just intermarry have children like regular humans
and these ones are born later it's just that they
have near infinite lifespans they can still be
killed by other eternals or beings that are more
powerful like you have the deviants that are
about as powerful as the eternals but then you
have celestials cosmic entities the very powerful
avengers characters but the idea is that when they
die at least in the comics i don't know if they're
going to do this in the movie but they reincarnate
using special technology created by the celestials
so it just plays into the idea that they can be
truly eternal i'll explain why the celestials give
them the crazy long lifespans it's all about the
mission that they create the eternals for there
is a purpose they aren't just tinkering with life
they actually want them to do things even though
it's implied that these eternal characters have
free will technically they do but they also kind
of don't but here's where these characters in the
movie are connected to thanos so thanos's father
is a large they canonize that during avengers
infinity war when he goes to vormir in red skull
basically tells him thanos son of a lars but his
father was actually born on earth millions of
years ago but thanos's grandfather kronos was
one of the original eternals one of the first ones
that celestials created one of the most powerful
ones and as the name implies as you probably
guessed he's the inspiration for the mythological
greek titan kronos like all the eternal
characters in the movie are worshipped as gods
by early humans because of their powers so modern
religions mythologies are created around them
mostly greek mythology but also other cultures
around the planet so through chronos thanos is
actually really closely related to athena angelina
jolie's character in the movie they're like first
second cousins but within the mcu athena isn't
really close with thanos or anything like that
they haven't seen each other in thousands of
years and even during the actual eternals movie
for the most part in present day when thanos was
attacking the planet the eternals weren't around
and a lot of people still wondering about that
they didn't help out because they did not have
their memories they didn't realize that they were
eternal they were just living amongst humans as
if they were normal humans they had families they
had normal jobs that they went to during the day
because they have that avengers end game tag
scene during the trailer they'll probably have
some moments during the movie where they address
this as they start to get their memories back like
oh one of our kind one of the other eternals was
responsible for all this destruction but you could
draw some parallels in the trailer and the way she
wants to train humans to fight here in mesopotamia
like they defend themselves against threats that
might come foreshadowing the eventual coming of
thanos someday in the same way that they're kind
of referencing captain america shield here with
this star on the old shield in these guards like
see how the eternals are connected to the avengers
in present day how they influence them without the
avengers realizing it like i wouldn't be surprised
if when they're training with the shields here
you see some moves that are similar to captain
america's moves some of you may have also noticed
in the trailer that you also see what seems like
the actual original captain america shield that
steve rogers used before he got the vibranium one
here in kingo's private plane when they're
partying like the eternals are collecting all
kinds of artifacts over the millennia filling
their spaceship other places like all these
other treasures from across the centuries that
they've collected you even see a psvr sitting
in the pile here so obviously this is in present
day when makari is reading this book but not all
these other eternal's main characters are directly
related to thanos the way that athena's character
is like i mean technically they're all related
in the way that they're all eternals genetically
like in the way that all humans on planet earth
share genetic similarities but in the comics you
have these different pockets of eternals living
in different parts of the earth that descend from
different lines so it's a little bit like the
black panther movie in the way they explain the
different tribes of wakanda like you have the
main panther tribe from whom all black panthers
descend the line of kings of wakanda but then you
also have the ape tribe currently led by umbaku
who follow very different traditions slightly
different culture over the centuries the whole
reason why thanos wasn't born on earth though like
the other eternals is because a long time ago the
eternals had their own civil war over what their
race should be doing on earth some of them wanted
to rule over humans some of them thought that
they should leave after the war was over a group
of them did leave the planet to travel the stars
there were more subsequent wars that were fought
and eventually a group settled on titan and that's
where thanos father came from met his mother who
was also from a different group of eternals
and then they sort of fostered the society
that became the titan that thanos is talking about
during avengers infinity war so for example when
thanos talks about being banished from the planet
it was actually his father that banished him from
the planet and the really cool thing about thanos
is that as someone who is fully eternal like he's
100 eternal dna he has all the benefits of being
an eternal with none of the special programming
built into him preventing him from fighting
the celestials like all the special celestial
technology that the eternals use to resurrect
themselves the exclusion zone where that happens
that only they're allowed to enter thanos can
actually enter that place he can use the eternal
gates that they use to teleport around they
don't really cover this in any of the movies but
hopefully they bring him back in some future movie
they'll have some easter eggs for stuff like this
so this is the entire celestial host that they
feature during the movie this is arishem the judge
their leader nezzar the calculator hargen the
measurer jemiah the analyzer eson the searcher
which obviously we saw during the first guardians
of the galaxy movie in knowhere for example the
disembodied head of a dead celestial i know
everyone's still wondering which celestial
it belongs to there's actually an answer for that
so according to most theories in some more recent
comic books like avengers secret wars knowhere is
actually the head of jemiah the analyzer because
also in that first guardians of the galaxy
movie there's a building that they walk into
that's named the boot of jemiah that's probably an
easter egg that they would cover in the eternals
movies that feels like a very kevin feige thing
to do like see how we're connecting things to the
modern mcu films showing you the celestial getting
his head decapitated in it becoming knowhere but
as for thanos coming back in new movies in marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5 i believe that there will
only be small references in easter eggs for thanos
in this first eternals movie maybe in eternals
2 eternals 3 whatever sequel movies they do then
we'd see thanos being born or larger thanos scenes
they could do a big flashback during eternal
sequels where they show you a big civil war that
they fought amongst themselves with a group that
then split off to develop their society on titan
and then show thanos being born during that then
you also have the other major untold stories that
they've teased heavily involving thanos to take
place closer to present day with adult versions
of thanos like the new origin of nova inside the
mcu there was that whole deleted subplot at the
beginning of avengers infinity war showing thanos
going to zandar to take the power stone then
destroying the planet the writers of avengers
infinity war and avengers end game said that
richard ryder would have been a lone survivor and
had a very thor-like stormbreaker revenge arc and
then would have come back for a small cameo scene
as nova in the final battle of avengers endgame i
did a couple videos about this a couple years ago
the russos made some jokes about nova in avengers
end game claiming he was in there but he's not it
was just meant to be a joke because they got rid
of that subplot before they finished the movies
macho man rooster brothers how do you guys not
have any nova court member in a fight against
thanos loved the movie but just boggles my mind
didn't even have to be richard ryder i look
closely at that scene again there and you will
see there are thousands of people yeah you will
see richard ryder in the background of a shot
easter egg eventually they will do a version of
nova in the movies in some form and they could
always use thanos in flashback scenes for his
origin story but everyone let me know in the
comments what you want them to do with thanos in
the eternal sequel movies and what other marvel
movies you would want to see him cameo in if there
any big questions you have about those characters
or what's going on with the movie just let me
know in the comments below i will do more eternals
videos as we get more footage and learn more about
what's going on all my loki episodes will start
posting next week so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any of
those click here for that eternals black knight
trailer video and click here for that brand new
spider-man no way home announcement that marvel
made about the future of the spider-man character
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!